-Guys, finally,
we have exactly one show left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 Days
of Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ One day left ♪
-That's right!
For each of the last 12 shows
before Christmas, we've been
giving one lucky audience member
a magnificent Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
So since there is one show left,
let's open door number 1.
Where are we?
-It's right over there.
-Here?
-Right here.
-Go for it, pal.
Ready?
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
It comes with a hat.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We have a hat, too.
Wow.
Okay.
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
Now let's see --
Now let's see who's going home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number -- if I
call your number, come on down.
Quest, could I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
238!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Come here!
Come on down.
♪♪
Yes!
Hello!
How you doing?
-Good. How are you?
-Nice to see you.
You can stand over there.
Hi.
What is your name?
-Mikayla.
-Mikayla, where are you from?
-I'm from Nashville.
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nashville in the house!
It can get cool sometimes at
nighttime in Nashville, right?
-Yep.
-Do you have anything
like this at home?
-I don't think so.
-How about the matching beanie?
Do you have anything like that?
-Nope.
-Would you like to try it on
for our audience?
-Oh, of course.
[ Cheers ]
-Do you want me to hold
your glasses or you got it?
You can han-- All right.
Mikayla, good job.
Be careful.
♪♪
-Oh, perfect.
[ Cheers ]
♪♪
-There we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.